[موسيقى]
المدينه المنوره تعتبر ثاني اهم مدينه
للعالم الاسلامي حيث تضم المسجد النبوي
وقبر النبي محمد حيث يفد اليها سنويا اكثر
من ثمانيه ملايين مسلم من شتى بقاع الارض
الان المنطقه صارت جدا جدا مكتظه بالحجاج
والمعتمرين التوجيه صار على جهه واحده
تركيز الحجاج كلهم سرعه جهه واحده
المساحات صارت اكبر تعدد الثقافات
فرصه تجاره جدا جدا كويسه في المنطقه هذه
من المدينه المنوره الى العالم هو عنوان
مشروع المنطقه المركزيه المجاور للمسجد
النبوي الذي يقع على مساحه 20 الف متر
مربع ويضم ثمانيه عشر مطبخا من مختلف
البلدان الاسلاميه
لتتناسب مع كافه اذواق الزائرين طوال شهر
رمضان اضافه الى مركز استعلامات
ومحله لبيع التذكارات ومسارات مهيئه الى
ساحات المسجد الحقيقه المكان رائع جدا هذه
الاختلاف
التعدد الدول بالاكلات والمطاعم الرقابه
الجميله الرائعه جدا يعني واحد من ياكل
مامن انه مطمئنه اني اكل هنا بهذا الاماكن
هي جوار وطمانينه هي مدينه الرسول عليه
الصلاه والسلام فاني لمست هاي الطمانينه
اللي احنا افتقدناها لسنوات طويله بالعراق
لكن اذا احب اشتري اشياء تذكاريه اشياء
كثيره يعني اشياء السجادات الاسلاميه
[موسيقى]
السلاسل الاسلاميه انا احب اكون اولادي
يتذكرون العمره اللي انا سويتها باشياء
جميله بيها طابع تراثي سعودي اسهمت
المشروعات الحديثه التي انجزت في المنطقه
المركزيه بالمدينه المنوره في تحسين
المشهد الحضري ورفع مستوى جوده الحياه في
الطرق والشوارع المحيطه
وتهيئتها بشكل اكبر للمشاه وقاصدي المسجد
النبوي الشريف من المدينه المنوره سلطان
السلمي العربيه
[موسيقى]